I think the process is important so
grant writing and science is important
it's difficult because the numbers are
so low and it's so hard to get funded
but at the same time while it's a
painstaking process it makes sense to me
mean in any business or industry you
have to show that you're going to use
the money wisely and you've thought out
through all the different options so for
me so far I've really enjoyed the
process this is the process of thinking
through in advance and looking at all
the different outcomes that could come
into play and whether or not it's a so
it keeps you responsible and it keeps
you thinking very proactively about
what's the best way to do your science
so I enjoy writing the grants and I
think it's important but at the same
time it's definitely difficult for a lot
of scientists because money is becoming
more scarce and this isn't a great time
for the national budget and science so
that that makes it difficult so
obviously I wouldn't want it if I you
know projections were you know the norm
for a long period of time but I see why
it's important I think like most people
you know we find our inspiration or our
excitement from all sorts of places so
and while there's a couple things that
are pretty fundamental to me like
medicine music I'm always you're always
dabbling right a hundred different
things and that's very much the kind of
these generation x and y's about like
exploring all sorts of things so when I
was at Oxford I really started getting
into the history of science so reading
all about all the early people and
evolution actually like Darwin and walls
but also hooker and Lyle and Memphis and
so I went this really big period of just
understanding the history of science and
that was like that definitely inspired
me and kind of made me think about a lot
of the process in a very different way
end up writing a play about it because I
got so into it you know lately and then
I go through these periods of just
really loving and then the fiction
writers so there's tons of them that I
like so it's hard to it's hard to say
like nick hornby i love alex garland is
great yeah it's actually hard to say
there's there's lots and lots of
different writers that I enjoy Oh
Frank portman king dork fantastic book
just really good really good if you like
music and and you have ever fantasy
banded it's a great book so you know go
through my fiction periods as well and
then I think more like lately I've been
reading a lot of the more nonfiction
like well because I'm starting eleven
reading a lot of management books from
the Harvard Business Review which is
excellent and but like Malcolm Gladwell
both blank and tipping point really
interesting for economics like so you
know you go through just different
periods where different things become
mini obsessions and I'd say right now
that another mini upset like so I've
many many obsessions like right now
still back to music but rock band is a
mini obsession i love it and I've never
the one instrument I never played with
drums and I think it's just a great it's
great for music literacy and it's just
great for like so it's my own personal
teacher right you're just like checking
and you're going through the different
you go through each song and you go from
like you know easy to medium to hard and
then you go through all the difference
it's so fantastic so I'm very very close
with my family and I think that you know
if you have to look at the Scott like
look at you know at your life in general
and probably no one's had a greater
impact on me than my family I'm close to
them and I grew up with them but that
they're just tremendous people that I'm
you know so my close family would be my
sister my mom and my dad just are all
just wonderful people really caring and
are so inspiring in so many ways just
the way that they look at life and my
mom is just one of these free spirits
and she's always been she's always been
she's all that mom then on field trips
in an elementary school was the one
everybody wanted to go in her car cuz
mrs. betty was like you know ridiculous
like played the lab music got the big
food you know always she made it very
fun she's a very fun mom and was very
into like us doing well in school but in
a way that made it that we wanted to do
it in her so she made it fun so I enjoy
what I do and it's always been very hard
so you enjoy the hard work and you enjoy
the payoffs and it makes it fun and you
know my dad is just an incredibly
resilient strong and we're
person who's always been the very
responsible caring person in my life I'm
a great deal respect for him and my
sister I was you know saying that before
has been she's definitely that because
she and my parents are great but she was
going through the whole process with me
so she was just one step ahead of me in
school she was always teaching me in
school she was always just a tremendous
influence who's incredible athlete so
she got you know I was always trying to
be able to like her so wonderful you
know I was very young when I moved over
I was you know like two going on three
so for me that memories are pretty
clouded I don't really know but i think
that there's a feeling of you see your
parents go through so much and you see
not not just my parents but my parents
generation going through so much of all
you know our friends and family all
transitioning and having to exodus from
their home country where they built an
entire life for themselves and have to
start over so there's some you know it's
it's definitely it makes you think like
whatever I mean America is such a you
know place of opportunity then nothing
that I went through would even come
close to what they you know what gone
through in our lives so I have
tremendous respect for my parents and
and every one of my parents generation
and seeing my parents attic said they're
really resilient and not just resilient
but happy and grateful I think that was
one of the things that I get from them
is that you know they're grateful for
the time that they experienced in Iran
they're saddened for what's happened to
the country and the people there now but
you know they do what they can but
they're also excited about their new
life so they've always been really
thankful for the opportunities America
gave them and their children and that's
what I kind of that's what I get from
them is the resilience and the
appreciation for life and every like
opportunity that they have
you